okay
connecting is this gonna work
i think we're live
welcome to the common body launch
uh i don't know if we can see comments
on here but can someone check if the
youtube's actually live you all have
phones
uh oh no it's upside down
is that okay
that is not okay
we're live
okay um
i should have thought about this before
i made it this way
it had to be this way
no no no
um hang on
let me think quickly of how to
that's upside down
uh
can we get a
allen key to flip this to the other side
so we can't turn the stream around we're
gonna turn
cameraman has his phone mounted on that
side so we're gonna mount cameraman's
phone on this side so you guys can see
the body launch filmed by a comma body
mike and billy are over here in the
audience
um hi mike
hi billy
uh yeah we're flipping it around welcome
everybody welcome to
the office
uh we're not going
starting the presentation for another 15
minutes so we have
music
we have comments on youtube
are any of them any good
[Music]
i shield on instagram live this morning
yeah
well no i don't know how to do that
that's too hard
technology is really hard guys all right
okay cameraman is holding my phone now
let's rotate cameraman a little bit
let's frame the shot
cameraman you need arms so you can hold
it
oh yeah perfect um so i'm sorry if it's
a little wobbly
you can blame research for having a
laggy localizer
good morning everybody good morning
[Music]
oh yeah yeah cameraman's a little a
little wobbly
all right um have you ever been on a
boat before it's like that
that's uh
[Music]
i tested it with the weight on the other
side
there we go
oh yes no cameraman no stay
okay you're being filmed by a common
body this is experimental technology uh
you'll learn
oh well
okay okay
chill
ashwagandha
um
people are going to complain about how
sick they are from watching this video
stabilization because
did you bring your shirt for your body
uh i have a flight jacket but that was
too heavy
oh buzz lost his flight jacket yeah
all right how much is youtube
complaining about the rocking
not much
i'm getting sick
come on
cameraman you know
normal people would lose their job for
this
someone ask what the body's pronouns are
um
look at how stable vehicle researcher is
oh cameraman you can learn it's cause
he's wearing a
mask it's on you great
all right you have a good framing of the
shot yeah you we do actually cameraman i
think you should close the door though
what
time
post it on twitter
okay you know what do we have some
blocks
no i asked for this today i want to jack
up my body for development
yeah yeah
we could put them on some we put them on
some blocks
we got
it's oh it's rocking back and forth
pretty bad oh that's fake
no we got we got we got like a cinder
block or something
no that won't fit
what do you mean i mean you have the
legs and then you have the uh yeah yeah
but i'll put a cinder block vertically
the bodies balance very stably when
they're not holding weight like vehicle
researcher my phone's heavy though
i got it stable
but i can't rotate it now
you change your mind i think this is the
perfect size oh wait is this a rtx 30
90 bucks perfect for playing minecraft
in 10 000 fps
oh let's zoom out here
um okay so i had to download some app to
do the youtube because the real youtube
app didn't work
ah
all right it's stable now we just gotta
frame the shot
all right wait i'll go ahead everyone on
discord
is
business
do we have a mirror so everybody can see
camera man
is buzz causing trouble
yeah he's definitely going to start a
fight
let's
cameraman's very stable
well
yeah but that's a later problem
uh who's in charge of youtube comments
what the
what are you doing
i'm gonna turn them
okay very carefully no no don't turn the
phone
you have to turn the rope if you turn
the phone it will go unstable again
okay
come here cameraman
i know i know a normal person will be
fired from your job but you don't get
paid much so
we keep you around
okay okay
no stay
you had one job to do and it was stand
still
okay
[Laughter]
okay
oh look he's stable now
we put him on some blocks
okay cool
uh check out how the shots framed
uh i'm sorry if you uh pull a long
distance to come here for this
all right is the shot good yeah it
sounds great on youtube what what's
youtube saying i want to know where the
other bodies are i agree you should get
some bodies
let's go
um
you wanna judge me do i connect to mike
and oh you guys you got something to do
we want the connector mike to drive
around
i tried connecting to billy this morning
you didn't miss anything why don't you
just get in here i missed nothing can i
see the stream
cameraman was trained on forty thousand
hours
do people there ever actually work
how do you think all the bodies this is
a different one right
you can control mike
where are you on channel
all right oh you were raped
i think it's worth it
oh
six minutes
oh
don't knock into camera he looks great
vehicle researcher is very stable turn
around
um
so all the code doing the balancing is
running in python
cameraman is the only employed body here
oh it's nearby can we move it into a new
office so we'll actually have like you
know space
twenty thousand square feet
yeah oh my god
hopefully you know you guys
see our
data
[Music]
well so we got two more of these r730
racks coming in and then we got another
data center of garage which is one year
it's all going to get re-reacted to
these guys
buzz do not knock it to cameraman you're
very close
all right we got four minute countdown
all right
we have 288 people i think we just
started we have 288 people in youtube
yeah
oh
okay if everyone's here i think we can
smart is the shock frame dweller these
bodies too much of the way no they're
great
i really think it'd be nice if it buzz
got it
all right okay am i gonna get bus back
in there oh well do not knock on camera
all right
it's a little bit more aggressive
so this is probably
one of the most recorded events because
well the bodies are all cameras
they're all they're all watching
so
what you see here are homo bodies
and they may not look like much right
now but they are the future of people
i want to remind everybody that one of
the people uh didn't look like the
future people you know
if you think about if you look at the
earth 40 000 years ago
you saw the ferocity of lions
the the
magnitude of elephants
or the speed of cheetahs
and you wonder how the little squishy
things
would come to inherit the earth
but here we are 40 000 years later
nobody questions
uh humanity's complete and utter
dominance over the animals when's the
last time you've seen a bear on the way
to the coffee shop
so the silicon people are coming
and you know it's not gonna take 40 000
years it's probably going to take maybe
about 40 and in 40 years nobody will
question the dominance of the silicon
and the reason humanity came
to dominate the earth is our brains
and these silicon grains are about to
go way past
human brains
uh one of these is maybe about
maybe equivalent to a human if you're
really real good software
and then if you've got a machine with
eight of these and a rack or 40 of these
as well
okay
so uh yeah
now of course uh you know if you talk
about all the eyebrow
singularity philosophical stuff let's
focus on the very concrete bodies are
very concrete one of the slogans we have
in common ai is real
a self-driving car is not [ __ ]
this is a weird
uh thing that's like been put into
people's head by images of google pod
cars and stuff
uh here's a here's a rolls royce and a
guy and the self-driving car is again
not the car it's
the guy
right you self-driving you see most of
the letters in self-driving car are
actually the guy and not the car
so we need to stop i mean like
you can look at these things special
purpose uh robots this is a vacuum and
this is a mocker the vacuum and the mop
have
exactly the same brain they're doing
exactly the same thing just one of them
has a vacuum attachment one of them has
a top attachment
then you know you have to buy the same
thing again when you go buy your robotic
lawnmower it's basically the exact same
thing it drives a path you use a slam
and all that and then you know you can
go even further with the special purpose
robots and then like this is why did
anyone build this right again a
self-driving car is not a car uh just as
these robots are not lawnmowers bumps
and bags
the thing that you want is one robot
that is vaguely human plus well you know
a vacuum
um you can buy on
amazon uh
um that you can buy on amazon a
lawnmower you find amazon and a car you
can buy on amazon uh so
yeah you you want you want to not do the
special stuff you want to just have one
human issue a lot all these things
so when you look at the comma three you
can see comma three is atop the five
bodies here the comma three is a head
it has two eyes
two ears
ah they're not active yet but it does
every country has two
uh it has a mouth maybe you've heard it
talk
uh it beeps right now but it's capable
of you know producing uh it has a very
good vocal tract that's capable of
producing all human sounds
it has a nose
maybe you've seen it brief
when it gets hot it breathes
out
uh it is brain
snapdragon 845.
maybe on par with a b brain
but you can see these things maybe have
the intelligence of bees
and then it has a spinal cord
you can look at the spinal cord running
you see my spinal cord right here
uh so this has a spinal cord that
connects to your car as well
uh working off his
power
so i guess the blood vessels built into
that this kind of works well for the
frame
in order to drive all the cars
people think oh what are you going to do
about toyota security how are you ever
going to support my
1968
ford pinto
well
stop thinking about it in terms of a
special purpose machine that connects to
a car and talks over some fancy
electrical interface and start thinking
about it as a machine that gets into the
driver's seat and presses the pedals in
this journey that's the real api for
cars and this api has been standardized
for a hundred years
so how do we build something that
interfaces with that api and the cool
thing is it also interfaces with the api
room and the api of the mock and the api
the lawnmower
of
the api of pots and pans and your stove
and all these things so what you really
want to build
is
it doesn't have to be
humanoid but it has to be humanish
so in order to drive all the cars clean
your houses cook your food et cetera the
comet re-needs a body
and this is the common body
here's the common three
here's the body and here's the human
person
this is what it looks like on top
this is what it looks like on the bottom
and you can buy it right now at
commonwealthbody.com
for 99.
so go out there and apply and we have a
little batting pool going on in the
office about how many bodies where we're
going
this is what the footage looks like from
the body this is from the office
you can connect your body remotely this
is from our europe office
so these things are fancy 360 degree
cameras
we've already shipped
uh about 20 bodies out
uh for body epoch
here's a user youtube video
uh well the body needs some some space
to get up to speed
we'll talk about a generic way to
address that up in a little bit
um
so yeah we've already shipped out the
body epoch problem uh program you know f
stands for experimental prototype
partner up tomorrow we ship out some
comma threes uh in the epot program as
well
watch that again
uh on and off with the bodies look like
clothes
this is what bodies look like naked
it's very compact ships to you only
domestic not international uh but it
folds up nicely and fits in a box it
comes to nice assembly instructions on
the internet
this is what the internals look like so
this is a hoverboard motherboard with a
custom board on top of it we also
replace the microcontroller on the
hoverboard motherboard with a stm
413. the exact same microcontroller
that's in the common tube common grade
white panda the right hand black panda
so it runs
panda software and it's talking directly
to the mos hex
which this means there's zero lag on
these motor controllers right you have
full control the software is all open
source uh that directly drives the
motors um
maybe uh you go you want to bring a
wheel out
yeah
um
you know when you think about
what these what these these wheels uh
audience things are and why this stuff
kind of wasn't possible maybe 10 or 20
years ago i go back to maybe
i remember in high school
2005
trying to buy a brushless boat and you
could buy brushless cars they were
hundreds of dollars
uh relatively low power and require
these very specialized motor controllers
in the last 15 years mosfets have become
like 10x more efficient you can get
mosfets that are the size of my pinky
that can switch kilowatt power
uh so you were going to bring a wheel
out i'll just show you how far these
things have come
these are they're hoverboardings
but they're
uh
they're sensored brushless motors
meaning
they have
three phases for the windings and then
they also have polish effect sensors you
can get instant starting torque and this
is all connected to the v413
microcontroller uh your current sensors
on two of the phases and then a general
turn sensor
on the whole thing this is what's on the
hoverboard motherboard
um yeah these are
these are lovely single
when you just look at this and that this
was
this kind of motor would have been so
extensive
uh 15 years ago negotiate magnets
brushless and you can get the
controllers are
cheap also
okay
we have to start
we didn't we thought about buying one of
those mesh suits
dressing somebody off having to come out
here and dance
but that's just ridiculous that's enough
science nation
uh this isn't the common way of doing
things
comedy is really
so how do you start
right
what is what is kind of the minimum
set of
stuff
required
to start
interacting with the human world in an
intelligent way
and
the answer is first let's start our
about with a with a way to move around
okay yeah you can build legs but why are
you spending time on that that's not
what the heart problem is
um robotics is 99 the software pro
if you had magical ideal software on the
body again like i like to think of
software written by god
if you had software written by god on
body this thing could already do so many
different jobs
right it could do all kinds of qa and
inspection it could do security
unfortunately software is really really
hard
so right now what does the body do well
the body balances
but
it has the same logging stuff as what's
in overpilot so we're going to start
gathering data from the bodies and we're
going to start training models that are
capable of the first task that we want
to focus on is localization
is being able to localize well
in the environment we have more than
enough cameras and i use in order to do
this
and then thinking about the
we're going to move the camera closer
move the camera closer yes
um
thinking about the general-purpose
robotics problem the same way we think
about the self-driving car problem which
is don't hand code it
what does it mean to build
well ai systems that don't you know that
interact with the real world
but don't have very specific
like oh we're going to detect a mop and
we're going to detect we're going to use
an a-star algorithm to plan
how our hand will wrap around that well
you can't do this
you have to you know think about
well what does end to end for the
bodybuilder
this is not an easy problem and i don't
have an answer to it
um i feel like
maybe about
three years ago we had the full solution
for self-driving cars uh i still think
we do
it's
complete we just have to fix all the
bugs and fixing you know saying just
fixing all the bugs is really really
really hard
but at least from a conceptual
perspective we have self-driving cars
solved and the question is what's the
next thing conceptually um
so self-driving cars are a lot easier
than uh safe cooking
because when you drive a car all good
drivers are good in almost the identical
way they'll take almost the same actions
given the scene
for cooking this isn't true
you can take a huge variety of actions
to make an omelette think about it does
it really matter if you put the pan on
the left burner or the right burner
or does it matter if you crack the eggs
outside the pan or inside the pan so i'm
grabbing shells right it's a much more
uh a lot like the
the loss function is much less maybe
convex than the loss function for
driving where all of the okay does it
matter if you're in the left lane or the
right lane no but that's a problem that
we can talk about very explicitly and
you can't really talk explicitly about
the equipment problem for cooking
robotics is 99 a software problem
openpilot is the best robotics platform
in the world and i'll justify the
statement
you can look at ross
um a lot of people in in the robotics
world are using ross
ross has a custom serialization format
uh ross has a
antiquated socket interface ross2 was
moving to
zmq
we've already moved past zmq so zmq is
this uh maybe somebody familiar with the
library we've written our own thing
called message queue and the big
advantage to message queue is you don't
have to make a copy so you can pass it's
a like publish subscribe interface where
you don't have to send the packets
through the kernel you can just allocate
some shared memory that shared between
the processes and this isn't academic
stuff
i'm sure many of you here today many of
you watching at home have open pilot on
your cars
this stuff is
tested for
over a million hours
uh it works at scale
it's it's just much more developed than
any of the stuff i've seen from robotics
maybe cars are one of the only examples
of working robots in people's lives
today like you can look at a roommate
it's a joke i got rid of my robot after
it destroyed my second macbook charger
so
how do we take all of the good stuff in
open pilot and apply it to more generic
problems
with the magic of software
anything is possible
we don't just want to watch the world
and now the bodies just sit there and
and watch the world
body adam gets
the knee is coming in late 2022. so we
started thinking about arms but one of
the problem with arms is if we put an
arm up here
well how useful is that right
you got to be able to pick up the vacuum
so you need a knee you need to be able
to bend down the knee also includes a
hammer
arms are coming in 2023
and the price point that we're targeting
for all this stuff
is on the order of thousands of dollars
so when you look all robotics in the
past has fallen into basically one or
two categories there's toys
generally which fall in the realm of
hundreds of dollars you have like lego
mindstorms
uh
you have
a lot of these sort of
toy robot kits i bought a little six
degree free tomorrow on amazon for like
200 bucks but they're useless
right or you have things in the tens of
thousands of dollars
uh you can think about like
baxter from the defunct grief think
robotics or you think about spot
dynamics is now shipping spots for 75
grand right that's well outside the
budget of most people but something
that's on the order of thousands of
dollars
it's not a toy it's
legitimately
well built you can look at these things
you'll have an opportunity to look at
these things much more close like a
solid aluminum base
uh 80 20 which is easy to attach things
to this is being filmed on a slightly
unstable body right now
um
it's it's professional grade robotics
for a price point that's 10x less
than
uh everybody else pretty much doing this
um
at this at this sort of level
so we're going to build arms we're going
to build arms that are capable of
lifting serious weight uh that are
capable of you know they don't have
backlash they're very precise encoders
on them they're not like hobby servo
motors
uh
look
the other philosophy also is minimal
actuators i believe when tesla launched
their bot they talked about 40 actuators
it's not quite [ __ ]
right well it's not going to shift for
any reasonable price
over here this is a body with a knee
and you can see that there's two
actuators one for the knee and one for
the hip this allows pitch control and
height control
of the camera
uh
these are the gearboxes that we're going
to be using again it's the same wheel
unable to play video error 5.
well
i have something better
using the same wheel
this wheel has nine foot-pounds of
torque 10 to 1 gear ratio 90 foot pounds
of torque
look
um
if you don't believe us
can we bring uh if we bring kenny out
here
there's one body you haven't met yet so
you've met cameraman uh you've met fawz
you met mike you've got a vehicle
researcher you've met billy over here
they're doing millions very stable
um
it's just like a normal thing
oh yes this is kenny um kenny's a little
bit taller uh
than the other bodies
these are those gear boxes i was talking
about ten to one cycloidal drives
zero backlash
uh we're going to put a very precise uh
magnetic encoder on them
uh
and then
we're not doing this in some tiny
microcontroller
so this is this is a good height i like
this i feel like
me and kenny were like
similar
um
this isn't being done this doesn't have
some tiny microcontroller which a lot of
these sort of toy robotics do it also
doesn't have
a fancy computer which is going to break
which is going to cause problems
like
you know you look at the boss dynamics
thing it's like a chorus 7 it's like a
full computer it loses all the beauty of
the reliability of embedded systems why
do you think phones took over from pcs
um it wasn't just their size
so it's the comma 3 which runs ubuntu
2004 it's open pilot and it's so easy
for us to do things like use mpc use the
same mpc we use for cars to control
these actuators uh to place
you know uh kenny in in different uh
positions part of the reason these
things are unstable is there's not that
much weight and the commentary is not
that heavy there's not that much weight
in the in the top part of the uh the
body so balancing like that's actually
pretty hard but with these sticks it's
going to be completely stable because we
know the exact position of these things
we compute exactly where the center of
gravity the thing is
um
so yeah kenny's gonna be able to uh
sit down
um
uh you'll be able to lay down stand up
completely
uh from from from completely laying down
and this provides a really good platform
when we attach the arms up here
to be able to crouch down
pick things up
so
you can be able to use bots and this is
shipping
at the end of the year and it's an
add-on kit for your body so if you buy a
body today
uh
we'll sell the knee add-on kit
you just replace
the bar
with this bar
attach it it's all on a can bus again
something that separates the hobbyist
robotics from the professional robotics
it's canvas this thing is basically a
car
it shows up to open pilot just like a
car as a fingerprint just like a car
so yeah
sorry kenny's not on
um
see on version of kenny probably in a
couple weeks
come with us on this journey
body support is already a master
on autopilot this is not
a separate repo it required very few
changes to autopilot to make these
things work um the localizer that's
running on the bodies to keep it stable
is the exact same localizer that runs on
the car
um it's even using the pose net that was
only trained on vehicle data and that's
one of the reasons for the
rocking back and forth but as soon as we
start getting data
from the bodies out in the field we're
going to put that training data into the
vehicle models as well
and
i think that it's not just going to
improve
the body but it's also going to improve
driving
because you have this problem
in uh
in the data that we get and the data
that we get if you're expecting a
rotation to the right
you're also expecting the road to be
curved right the action taken by the car
is correlated to the environment it's
extremely correlated to the point that
even though this isn't actually true or
the inverse of this is whatever you try
to train a simulator from driving data
what you end up with is a simulator that
when you tell the car to steer right the
road curve's right that's how it works
right
humans no that's right the steering
wheel controls the curve of the road
obviously um and there's nothing in the
data to really show that that's wrong
because there's no points in our data
except for some really really extreme
ones uh which are more rare than data
bugs
where the human sees a right turn and
turns left and like say smashes into the
wall right
you as a human have no problem
visualizing this everyone imagine a
light right banking curve on a highway
and taking the wheel and going like this
you all have no trouble imagining what
will happen
but you don't
you can't imagine this because you've
ever been in a car that did this you've
never been in a car that did this you've
never been in a car that was on a
lightly right bank turn on the highway
and somebody turned the wheel left and
smashed into a dividing wall
but you can imagine no problem because
you have a generic model for how
uh physics looks
for how um uh what's the word how like
projective geometry works how you expect
the scene to change based on how you
move through space
you got this because you didn't drive
for the first 16 years of your life
for the first 16 years your life you
were in environments that look a lot
more like places the body will be in and
by jointly training the models on
driving data
and body data
we can teach the car the same things
we still have to hand code so the big
thing the way that we made laneless work
and the way that we're gonna make end
and longitudinal work is by using a hand
code of simulator but the simulator is
not hand coded in the sense that we call
the behavior of other objects the thing
that we're coding are these rules of
projected geometry
uh so
hopefully
with the body
they can learn us
things not to buy so these are our
competitors
um this is a segway lumo this is an
amazon astro
and i'll tell you what's wrong with both
of these things they are small and
deserve no respect
would you respect something that was two
feet tall
two feet tall is about the height
of kenny's knee
do you respect this thing
but seriously
like imagine you like broke into a
building and this thing showed up
and these 90-foot-pound motors started
moving
we're building robots people respect not
robots that what do you do what do you
do when you see an amazon astronaut
imagine you broke into a place that was
an amazon astro what's your first
instinct
exactly
you're going to kick it
you want to kick kenny
you can try
kenny might kick you back
uh so you know it might be the biggest
when you search for a security robot you
get this company nightscope robotics
nightscape robotics is again one of
these companies that's in this 10x
overprice they're charging 70 grand a
year for their robot
we already have all the stuff for
security right you've seen common
connect we're going to roll out sentry
mode to the cars
um so why not also do the same thing
for the robot we have all this this
logging infrastructure uh you know
security robots for like five grand
that
set it up
and this is gonna deter people a whole
lot more than uh
you know a camera that they might not
even see
sit down kenny
come on
uh i just like here here this is for her
that's like to scale
so
buy your body today commonbody.com
9.99 uh ships in one to three months
first in first out
and that is the common body
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right who's got questions
hey kenny what you want to share you
want to share your seats
um
as someone who is not really
familiar with machine learning and stuff
i would be wondering like
how many people would they really need
to buy this and provide enough footage
to have an impact
on a model or trading forward well not
that many
but probably something like uh
20 hours of footage will be playing
um even if we're the only ones with them
when we're using them around the office
of course don't know
like a small amount of data that just
completely breaks the correlation of
when i see something that looks like
this this happens to start to learn the
actual physics of the world instead of
just uh also you know
on a car you can't explore
so if you think about i
if you think about in in reinforcement
learning you have this um explore versus
exploit
right uh maybe
this is also referred to as a
temperature parameter
uh
where sometimes you take an action that
isn't the optimal action for a scenario
just kind of see what will happen do it
sometimes randomly well you can't really
do this on a car
uh but on the body you can it's it's a
much
as a development environment it's a much
uh
lower stakes
a place to try out changes to open pilot
as as open pilot gets better and better
on the cars
it becomes
harder and harder to just like mess with
something whereas on the body
you know the it's still developing on
the body is fun
all the low-hanging fruit is still there
you want to make that guy not rock back
and forth spend 20 minutes tweaking the
pid loop and it'll probably
you know spend a little bit of time
learning like he rocks back and forth
because he has a he has a uh
he has a hoodie on uh billy's wearing a
nice lightweight t-shirt
uh okay learn the parameter for the for
the way that you think
all right that's the learner on there
like you can do that you can play with
this and it's it's fun unlike you know
trying to do that car
so does it balance right now based on uh
machine learning
um so the lowest
the localize is based on machine
learning so it's the local it's the same
localizer that's running in the car
it's using the gyro it's a common filter
but the pose net is is all machine
learning the postnet is trained on
vehicle data so once we start adding a
few body segments uh that'll all just
will just work
um doing controls with machine learning
like the state of the art
maybe the state of the art is boston
dynamics none of boston dynamics
controls has anything to do with machine
learning
you can watch videos about how boston
always does controls they use machine
learning for vision and for some other
stuff but the basic control loops are
this
state space linear model transition
thing
so yeah i mean classical controls are
just
you don't want a lot of parameters in
your control system because you don't
want
it's not high dimensional space
right like like vision's a very high
dimensional space so
you know you can you can
learn a lot easier than trying to learn
something
that's well it's you know your your
output is is four dimensions and your
input space is not that big either say
the input space of the whole camera it's
not really the one
how many dimensions do you really want
to reduce to first
uh so yeah the classical stuff still
does better than
machine learning stuff but this will
start to change and then the other thing
about the what you can do on the body
that you could never do on the car is
you can do reinforcement learning on the
body if you want to do on policy
reinforcement learning like again it's a
low stakes
uh space so
go get your download your open ai gym
cart call solver
you know car pull it up with an ai gym
it looks like this and run another body
and
maybe it'll work go try it i will
so
i'm not that fluent with machine
learning but what i'm understanding is
that if self-driving is like what would
a human do in this situation and you got
the answer because you got all the data
from the camera as well
but in this situation i don't really see
the answer so i guess you just said
reinforcement learning but i think
like it's a very different dimension
it's a lot harder yeah so the
well i mean the answer could be the same
right so you can see you can say the
same thing right like say i want to you
know i want i want uh you know kenny
here to learn to make omelets well the
human has a policy for making almost and
kenny should learn the same policy
now you're right it feels different from
driving the driving policy seems a lot
easier to talk about and i think it's
due to the uh like linear linearity i
didn't mean convexity before linearity
of the space right like when i mean the
space is linear i mean it's like well if
you're driving here
if you're driving like 20 centimeters
off it's almost the same thing if you're
putting the egg 20 centimeters off
that's a very different thing right the
loss function is so much less like you
know whether you put the egg on the
right side of the pan or the left side
of the pan doesn't matter but you put
the egg just a little bit over the pan
and no now your stove's a mess and you
know kenny gets fired
uh so yeah i mean what is the loss
function there well what's your loss
function because human function
good way
so like machine learning is
i'm saying that like the
the loss functions right now that we use
for driving in our driving model
um is basically a uh
i don't know if there's the gaussian and
laplacian but it doesn't really matter
it's it's some it's some shape that
looks like this right it's a very convex
shape um whereas the uh lost landscape
for things like cooking uh don't look
like this
and that's that's the the difference now
this one's function by the way isn't
perfect for driving
um
we can express some amount of stuff in
the like we have we have a mean and a
standard deviation you can look at our
models but
uh it's not
perfect to express like
well okay but that's a cone you really
don't want to hit that you can go on
either side of it
kind of i mean actually it's not just i
mean the standard deviation it's it's
multimodal as well so there's five modes
but
yeah you want a more complex loss
function than this
like what i'm understanding it's
actually very different from boston
dynamics because that banks have like
certain goals you basically like their
ai inside you still hardcode everything
but here you're saying like you learn by
yourself
learn certain qualities
yeah i mean boston dynamics is largely
remote controlled right like the spots
largely remote controlled but they're
still using on top of the remote control
a lot of sophisticated control stuff so
it looks good so the bodies are remote
control as well
but the remote control doesn't remotely
control the torque on each wheel you'll
never be able to drive it right but take
a remote control for a drone
imagine a remote control for a drone
that has four throttles
good luck flying that drone right
but you have all this dynamic
stabilization stuff running on the drone
and gotten very very good to the point
that you can give it a high level
command of you know move your position
here or rotate uh so we kind of want to
get to the same
point with this stuff so we have i've
been driving down the latency streamer
up from this thing it's about 200
milliseconds right now
uh to stream that back to a computer the
joystick control is instantaneous
uh not as case but like sub 10
milliseconds um
so i want to drive that down to 100
and then i want to write map for a vr
headset put the vr headset on and you
can drive it and this is going to be i
think a nice way to drive the arms as
well you'll be able to use the oculus
controllers
you know where you place the oculus
controllers where you place the arm uh
you know you want a knee like this going
to pitch like this
right and we can put things like the
goal pitch angle the goal height
um
the goal center of gravity the goal
speed
into
a solver the center of gravity
acceleration but we could put that into
like a like a mpc solver and it'll
output
actual low-level commands to the motor
we might even have like the way we have
it on the cars right now is we have mpc
which takes the model stuff and turns it
into a plan um
trajectory so the model outputs a plan
one of the things about a plan is the
plan doesn't have to start at the center
of the car i can start over here of
course you can never actually do that
so the model predictive control turns
this is the car against this into this
computer kind of uh
recovery trajectory and then there's
even lower level stuff like we have a
pid controller and one of the steering
loops in there also the actual like
controller car with torque uh you want
to command it to an angle because pid
looked for that npc was the angle
yeah i was just very
attracted by the ideal like the end goal
and then i didn't know how it would go
there but you know explain quite good
like get the controls first yeah like
it's unclear if these controls are
necessarily bad right like you might
want your machine learning to not have
to deal with the lowest level torques
maybe you eventually do but that's not
where the low hanging fruit is for this
stuff the thing that you really want to
avoid doing that we're never going to do
is like you never want a cone guy
because what's a cone
that's a really hard question what does
it mean to control something to an angle
that's a very clear question
now you might not be able to do it your
noise model might not be perfect pid for
example can't deal with things like
latency but you know it's it's a you can
still talk about it in very
physics-based ways where there's no
physics definition for the comments
we got any questions from youtube we do
what we got
how do you go about collecting data
about learning human cost functions for
things like cooking
well
so
we think about what the actual
intermediary goals of the body are uh
this thing is not going to be making you
an album anytime soon do not buy it with
the expectation i do not want to hear
and support
oh you know i didn't make an omelette i
put it behind the skull and pulled it
today
um
so yeah uh
how do you collect that data well here's
one idea we have
so like i said i want to write a vr app
uh and you guys can do it this is all
open source um you know we'll do all
open source that streams uh the
consortium of this thing back to the
headset and let you control the arms so
one way we can train it is
can you make an omelette in telepresence
can you use the body
use the arms using the full human brain
and our controls good enough to kind of
smooth over
this is still a really really hard
problem and a really valuable problem
building a telepresence robot that's
capable of making an omelette under
human control allows us to outsource
the job of your chef
to bangladesh
right
but think about it if we could build a
good
just a good telepresence robot we've
enabled this labor arbitrage for a whole
set of jobs where it never previously
existed
wow that sounds like a trillion dollars
oh that sounds boring
i'm part of the common discord some
people had some questions so
you you kind of compare this to the
uh like enterprise robots as opposed to
like
um so i
considerably it is steeply priced you
know to some that is understandable are
you going to be warranting like that
board components because i think some
people heard that once
you guys put out four components in it
why is it so expensive and it's kind of
risky if you don't like the price don't
buy it like that's all of that yeah
um another thing from the discord
somebody asked will it be able to go
upstairs
uh well
look at it
again
again
software is magic
um could could kenny make it upstairs
well if you put enough weight here
how am i doing that
do people
what
well i'm not using my think about it
it's how can i jump right cause i have
weight here
do this
[Applause]
so yes uh canyon can jump
how will this impact open pilot is this
two products now is this taking priority
is it a separate department
um
so it's the same problem right
is it really different from driving
all the things that are specific to
driving are things that you probably
shouldn't be putting that much time into
anyway uh there's a
i think who wrote it uh richard sutton
the reinforcement learning guy wrote
like a hard lesson of ai
what sudden sun yeah
um once you read this uh
basically
the
uh
the more time you spend
thinking about how to hand code
something the more time you're wasting
like it's going to be replaced by
machine learning it's a question of when
so the body forces us to think about
what things were hand coding on the car
and
if they don't work for the body
we have to ask why
so
what is our our company goal our company
goal is to solve self-driving cars
because if you can't solve self-driving
cars you definitely can't make an online
uh it's way hard
so is this going to uh we changing the
company goals we're giving up on
openpilot oh no
it's the same problem
i think that just like the model with
both data with with both body data and
driving data will end up learning
something that's better at both the body
and driving i think that open pilot will
end up being better at driving because
of the body and we would have done in
other words
i'm just reading the questions
they want to know does the body have to
watch me cook
to cook
so
does it have to watch you cook i mean
that's that's even harder right so
one of the really nice things about
driving as a problem is the car
is a
digitized system already
the car that you drive is the same car
that open pilot drives
if the body watches you cook it's not
then controlling you it's controlling
itself
so
being able to like learn using mirror
neurons the way humans do
is
really really hard and we haven't even
started to consider how to do any of
that yet
um is the body going to be able to watch
you cook to learn to cook uh ask me to
get in five years
don't expect any of that if you're
buying a body expect something that
stands up oh by the way
the other thing about the knee
which you'll get right away when you get
a knee
is right now the body has a top speed of
three miles an hour
um
largely because it has to lean over too
far
and accelerating is really hard when all
you have is this
uh this is not how a human accelerates
on a hoverboard a human accelerates on a
hoverboard by
uh shifting the weight forward and
that's what kenny did
uh
balancing is about six hours uh driving
around the joystick
uh it can
the batteries are really nice they have
like a built-in bms you can like stick
more batteries on if you buy more of the
batteries and you hook four of them up i
think it would just work
um you know eventually maybe sell the
call of the stomach just fill it with
batteries
uh but you do the math you do the math
on 2000 calories and how many watt hours
2 000 calories is i forget what it is
exactly but it's like within the realm
of feasible
it's like within the realm of feasible
that you can fit a day's worth of human
power in in in batteries
um
you know once you have the arm it will
be able to plug its own charger you know
you don't want to make a charger dock
well you need a charger dock right
humans don't have this i have a feeding
tube put the food in your mouth right
right
magic is softer is there a specific task
we'll focus on first
uh
balancing
if you're expecting the body to do
things it's not for you
um if you're expecting a high quality
robotics development kit that's fun to
develop with the body might be for you
but a specific task i mean like
all of the tasks that are really all use
a good business where it's synergistic
with the driving problem uh we'll focus
on the body like sentry mode for example
right like sentry mode is both useful in
cars and useful
on bodies imagine this thing stands
there sends you a text message to
someone uh
you know comes into your house
should i try to make my own body you can
what ability are you most looking
forward to the bot
body having
uh
oh man
i'm not like if i was elon i promise you
that it would like you know
it's going to vacuum your floors by the
end of the year
but you know that's like i'm not you on
so
are you saying it's too far out to even
like think about that
it's not what it's too far out to think
about it's that i couldn't give you any
timeline on it it's hard enough to make
timelines of when we're going to ship
0-8-14
we're really bad at timelines everyone
is everyone is you're the only
everyone's bad at timelines the only
question is how honest you are with
yourself about this right some people
are very dishonest and managed to
continually do this right it is amazing
like people will say that they'll have
something done in in in two days and
they don't have it done in two days and
they'll tell you in two days by the way
there's going to be two more days and
they do not and you're like okay can we
like like eventually you'd think that
something about the human would uh you
know correct this this broken loop but
the reason you don't is because like
there's two ways to estimate timelines
one way to estimate timeline is to think
about each task you're like okay well if
i want to make something that um vacuums
okay well first we're gonna have to be
able to pick up a vacuum okay well maybe
that's like a you know maybe that's a
two month project okay and then we're
gonna have to be able to like move
around it's maybe a little harder maybe
that's like a three month project so
we'll be able to vacuum in five months
but this is an absolutely terrible way
to think about this um a much better way
to think about it is how long have
projects like this taken in the past and
it's taken us maybe five years to learn
to drive cars as well as we have so five
years to learn to pack them though like
again
maybe it's a similar order of magnitude
problem which maybe it's very hard
have you guys tried like small like
small projects internally and see how
like maybe like avoiding a table like
but this isn't a good way to think about
it right this is the same problem as
like oh well you know oh my god the
people who walk like well can you just
add an adjustment to open pilots we can
adjust the position in the lane
like no
no this is a huge waste of time right
and it's the same thing with the thing
that avoids the table right like
yeah sure you can waste you know what
you can write a prototype of that in a
week right i'll download the latest yolo
v7 and put it to something else now and
put a table detector and all you that's
that and it'll avoid tables 80 of the
time i'll make a really good video that
doesn't show the broken 20 percent and
it'll look impressive right but it's a
stupid waste of time right so no this is
the wrong way to think about it people
think about driving like this too people
like well let's start with an easy task
uh you know like like like but
you do this and
if you're not focusing on the problem
holistically you're not getting anywhere
towards solving it um there's a saying
about self-driving cars the self-driving
cars are demo complete
uh meaning
you can build any arbitrary demo
get any blind band across austin in your
in your thing and you still are
just as far away from solving
self-driving cars as you were when you
started
um the demo air is useless
there's a lot of good insights in the
youtube comments
what do we got they
they say it's a it's a problem we didn't
know we had we've uh
invented an entirely new space
and that might be why some people have a
hard time understanding how it can be
useful
but
oh sorry or
you know a bunch of people on reddit
there's something that's really full of
haters um think about this as like some
like cynical uh business or or uh
marketing move uh like
look at me right it's possible that
everything about me is a lie and
everything about my identity is
constructed in order to do but does that
really make sense
or
think about it a lot more like you know
we're kind of like an ai research lab
i like to make things that actually ship
i think a lot of people here really like
that like using the things but it's not
like
there's no there's no
and next week we're going to announce
our partnership with with
uh the city of beverly hills to have
bodies standing on the corner deterring
microaggressions
right like no
um
you know it's just cool and it's it's
it's cool to
to think about so in terms of like if if
you're viewing this from a very
utilitarian perspective like kyle the
body improved my life don't buy one
and i feel even the same way about the
comma stuff like people who are buying
it for that purpose and making it very
like clear
oh well i have to think about how many
how many how many rational gnats of how
many how many gnats of happiness i will
gain by purchasing this oh my god i
can't believe people think like this
it's just cool man they want to know
more about the arm oh you learn more
about the arm all right so what is the
knee
um the knee is a two degree of freedom
uh thing we really want to keep the
actuators to an absolute minimum but
with the arm we're gonna need six right
so you need six degrees of freedom
because you want your end effector uh to
be placed in any xyz position and in any
roll pitch you want
so what i'd really like to design is
like a four degree of freedom shoulder
that can do so you can do like the polar
interpolation of the shoulder as well as
the rotation of the shoulder
in like a three degree of freedom thing
and then because you want to keep the
motors as close to the thing as possible
right the less inertia your your arm has
been moving uh the better it is um and
then the fourth motor will be here and
then belt into the bicep right so four
degree of freedom assembly here as close
uh to the to the to the non-moving part
of the arm as possible
and then you have three you have two
more degrees of freedom
to get your six
you have uh wrist
and forearm rotation
so you can use relatively small motors
for that uh and then the hand
the hand is even harder than the arm
we were just thinking the first uh would
have a gripper similar to the one on the
spot
if you saw the spot arm i don't exactly
like how the spot arm does its six
degrees of freedom because they're not
the human ones uh the spot arm does not
do uh
can't do this
it puts this rotation axis over here
it's still six but it's not the human
sex
i'd like the human sex
they're making a lot of comments
if you can pull this off it'll be huge
it's a long-term project make driving
chill and it has the body will make what
i don't know i came up with make driving
chill like three years in tacoma
we'll
figure out what the [ __ ] the body is way
less utilitarian than the open pilot
like
it's it's it's more in the in the
research direction it's not like don't
buy it expecting it to do something buy
it expecting it to learn things buy it
if you buy a body and you
work on it for
i'm going to give a shout out to dean
lee
lee's a guy in china um he's one of the
biggest contributors to open pilot
and
open source he started out
where he started out and where he ended
up the
change in his programming ability over
those two years is unbelievable
so you buy this you legitimately try to
like write features for this try to
improve it
you know you'll become
people always asking people always
asking how do i become better at
programming well it's like well how do i
get you know big arms right we got to
lift weights man
i just want the one magic trick no
there's no one magic trick go to the gym
ever again okay
uh so it's like that
is this just a meme response to tesla
can you just admit that
um well we saw tesla do it and tesla had
this was a revolutionary idea we never
ever thought before
about building
uh
bodies but when we saw tesla do it we
were like we put our top guys on it and
we're like we're gonna copy that and
what we did was we put a broomstick on a
hoverboard
no
it's an obvious idea right like think
about it people are always saying how
are you going to deal with the fact that
the car manufacturers are going to lock
you out
and i mean like sure we could do it with
hacking or we could do it by just
building a human
right and then we consume people you
know we gotta get we gotta get this
added to the anti-discrimination laws
don't discriminate based on brain
biochemistry
like just because they're silicon and
metal like hey man
no
blur
they're asking about if the hardware
will be open source oh
i'll tell you why not um open source
hardware benefits uh
call makers and clone makers and only
clone makers um
we don't open source hardware
because
it benefits clown makers uh
you think oh well okay there's going to
be individuals going out and building
this not really
uh like
it's it's
hardware has so much it's not like
software right like
a software is built using a compiler and
the compiler is also open source and you
can download it you can have software
running uh in no time the body has an
intricate supply chain which involves uh
so you're like oh it uses hardware
corner parts it uses hoverboard wheels
um the motherboard is reworked like
crazy we pull off the knockoff
microcontroller on there we put a real
stm on there uh you know we decided
resistors we put another circuit board
on there it's a custom aluminum milled
plate
uh like it just due to the supply chain
complexity open source hardware does not
benefit the individual yeah i think we
should make it clear it's not just a
hoverboard we stuck a poll on
there's quite a bit under the hood yeah
yeah
for our late
arrivals you didn't see the picture have
you ever seen a hoverboard that has a
solid aluminum plate on the base like
that
we can
any actuator for neck
um
no
ask why you need it
right if you want so you can think about
the three degrees of freedom for the
camera you all pitch and roll uh pitch
will be handled by the knee uh yaw is
handled by the base wheels and why do
you need to roll
yeah i think why aren't more people
using shipping first hardware strategy
in robotics
shipping first hardware strategy because
they're run by loot business losers who
were like well we have to figure out
what the application and the target
consumer is for this
i think it's i just i hate that
mentality so much i think it's this
mentality that you like you're you're
managing people like you view people or
customers it's like something to be
managed and analyzed and
bro like i don't know
i think this is pretty cool
to be honest would i have an open pilot
thing in my car
maybe not this rev
give it a little more time for the
software to get more mature maybe when
1.0 comes out it's just easy because
like my car is something i actually rely
on but would i buy one of these yeah
probably
why don't we have more robots already
you think
because robotics because software is
really hard and because
with driving i mean the comment
mentality is uh deliver shift for
intermediaries and there are nice
shippable intermediaries in self-driving
uh that don't involve level five right
open pilot can already provide a lot of
value to people building a robot that
provides any value at all is quite hard
and we do have robotics you just don't
call it robotics right there's a saying
in ai it's something is called ai until
it works then it's just called software
right no one like there's like search
algorithms oh yeah search algorithms
that's ai today you know there's a
right
sky
like oh now deep learning is kind of
well no i mean that's not like they like
but once they oh man oh it's like oh
doing this you know fancy like got a
consciousness or something right like
it's the hard problem that always gets
pushed out so robotics is the same way
right
you have a robot in your home it washes
dishes it's called a dishwasher but you
don't call it robotics because it works
robotics is just cold all the things
that don't work
what kind of
open positions will be for the common
body department
um
i mean
if there's someone out there who like
knows a lot about mujoku
uh so we're not doing any sort of like
real classical stuff
but
if
if you know the kind of control theory
that's going to let you
build good models of these actuators and
build a good simulator
uh we're interested if someone wants to
come work on the simulation environment
for the body
uh i'm interested and you might not
think you have the skills for this but
like if you're like like a game
developer like that sort of person
someone's going to build a great fast
reliable simulation environment for the
body
and test it to the real world not some
theoretical academic model uh i would
hire you uh but i think that would be it
for the body positions
yeah we can put some comma body parts in
the comma part shop maybe yeah seems
reasonable i dropped the body uh
two days ago and broke this top piece
well open source the top piece here so
we'll source this mount you can
print other mounts if you'd like to
mount other things to your body
curious why we used a hoverboard
what else did we consider
oh nothing i built the first prototype
karma body like a year and a half ago
now i went to best buy i bought a
hoverboard went to home depot bought a
pipe
and stuck it on there
and then like they don't balance on
their own so you have to write software
to do that but
uh what else do we consider i mean
nothing look at this wheel
look at this wheel
cheap available 250 watts the only
reason these motors are we say 150 watts
is because we're not running them at 36
volts you can run the motors at 36 volts
and get 250.
um
at a board maybe not but
the motors you can definitely do that
like it just has so much power at such a
low price point
that they're amazing
all right i think that's kind of it from
the
youtube cool yeah we're we're almost
done what's that eleven o'clock
and we've got one last question
mama you know anyone here for now
so you referred to
sort of uh the idea of like interacting
with things in the real world is kind of
like a human oriented api
if you're controlling
a car as long as you're not locked out
you're basically controlling an api
that's been provided for you to control
those various things so
it seems very hard to
if you think about you know making an
omelette or doing laundry or many many
other things
each thing seems like an individual
challenge that is quite difficult even
if you have all those degrees of freedom
so ultimately
is there sort of an
interim step where a device like a
vacuum or a
washing machine might know that it's
being talked to but know that it's being
controlled by such a device
and make it easier for such a device to
interact with it versus having to do all
the human things needed to do extra work
this is a bad way to think about it this
is the same sort of people who are
thinking like well wouldn't it be nice
if we upgraded our city with smart
streets for self-driving cars
right like like
this whole mentality
it just involves like
the reason that cars have apis to
control steering has nothing to do with
8as features and everything to do with
the fact that electrical power steering
saves you one mile per gallon on the
road right they've repurposed something
that already exists to provide this
small value-add feature they did not put
in
um the
adaptive cruise control like
it involves a slight change to the
braking controller but all the valves
are still there they're the same valves
being used for traction control they're
the same valves being used for anti-lock
brakes
right like
because these things were repurposed and
already in the car you managed to get
these apis but i would not try to like
don't make the world conform to you
conform to the world
cool thanks for coming out we got some
got some food
uh
yeah this is uh
where where
we're trying
all right
and we're honest
the body is an honest product
it's not a man dancing in a mesh suit
and the man dancing in a mesh suit is
still leaps and bounds beyond what
you know what does google promise in
roblox
they make some vague emotional claims
about how robots and humans are going to
coexist
like this is this is
like show me a real thing or shut up
like
so you know i really
subscribe to this mentality and like uh
we showed you a real thing you know
it'll get better over time slowly
iteratively
honestly
one more question
um so not too compared to a boston
dynamics robot but if you were to kick
one very hard
would it fall over oh sure
um
it's hard so you can't with just having
the wheels down here you can't really
prevent it
but with this one
uh i think this one we could get to
withstand any human camera
um because you can you know shift your
weight especially if you have weight up
here
right like if you if you put
you know two big arms here that way that
way 30 pounds yeah when someone kicks it
you know
okay i got 30 pounds of weight
stabilizing here i move my actuators
quickly
so no not that body but this body with
the magic of software
remember also boston dynamics showed one
video that they kept you know they
didn't have like uh like a
carnival day where they invited average
people in off the street to kick the
robot
now that that's this this is the
difference between a demo and reality
um i bought a spot and i kicked it and
it fell over
please help
all right thank you all for watching
youtube
uh how many people
we got about 300 people right now 300
people do we want to give them a bagel
the bagels look at me oh you got to go
get your own bagel that's what you get
for being remote